FOR THURSDAY MAY THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER. PLEASE READ ADVISER
AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS BEING MADE
IS ALSO BEING TELEVISED.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC OF
ATTENDING THIS HEARING MUST
WEAR MASKING ALL TIMES AND
COMPLY WITH GUIDANCE ON
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. ATTENDEES
MUST ALSO REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING.
VIOLATION OF THE RULES ARE
SUBJECTED INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL
OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS.
OF MISTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM SENATE FLORA YOUR
GIPSON HERE WE MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS YOUR RAMOS YOUR RUBIO
VEHICLE WHAT. WEBER WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE
A CONSENT AGENDA IS OUR
EMOTIONAL EXTENDED GENDER.
MERCERVILLE WAS SECONDED BY MR
LEE A MISTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM BENNETT FLORA FLORA
HI GIPSON HI GIPSON HIGHLY. LEE
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE RAMOS RAMOS
I RUBIO VEHICLE ARE YOU PRETTY
WELL I WEBER. WEBER HI. MOTIONS
PASSED OF THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING I'M GONNA SIT HERE FOR
A MOMENT YES I HAVE A
COLLEAGUES IN.
TWENTY ZERO. IN
THIS ROLE HAS EARNED.